dann darfst du noch Salz und Pfeffer
dazu machen wie viel
so wie die Mama
ich weiß es
[Musik]
falsch gemacht
okay
hallo herzlich willkommen
in Sallys Welt
tschuldigung von vorne ja
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys und
Samiras Welt ja
okay heute möchten wir gemeinsam
Abendessen kochen denn wir haben Hunger
also ganz einfach beim Hunger wir wollen
was einfaches machen was wir alle zu
Hause immer lieben sind Kartoffeln aus
dem Ofen und oft essen wir sie
tatsächlich einfach mit Joghurt das hat
er richtig stichfester heute haben wir
uns aber gedacht wir haben noch viele
viele Tomaten aus dem Garten die müssen
echt endlich mal verbraucht werden und
deswegen gibt es Ofenkartoffel mit
brusketta und Sauerrahm ja ganz lecker
und dafür haben wir hier schon
Kartoffeln gewaschen deren Schale man
auch mit verzehren kann das macht uns
die Arbeit gleich ein bisschen leichter
dann habe ich Olivenöl und zwar unser
Rosmarin Olivenöl Salz und Pfeffer
wir schreiben euch auch die Menge
einfach in die App und auf dem Blog aber
wir machen jetzt einfach mal so die
Menge und fürs brusketta nehmen wir
Olivenöl das ist normale etwas
Weißweinessig oder ihr könnt auch weißen
Balsamico nehmen Tomaten Salz Pfeffer
und Knoblauch und für die Sour Cream
haben wir 200 Gramm 200g
sauere Sahne und Schnittlauch und Salz
und Pfeffer gut und wir teilen uns jetzt
die Arbeit auf damit wir gleichzeitig
fertig sind
würdest du die Tomaten in schöne Würfel
schneiden
und ich habe den Ofen schon vorgeheizt
Heißluft und kann hier die Kartoffeln
die wie gesagt bereits gewaschen sind
schneiden und die schneiden wir jetzt
einfach in dicke Scheiben schön
gleichmäßig damit sie gleichmäßig gar
werden und ich nehme dafür jetzt einfach
so zwei Holzstäbchen und kann hier mit
dem Messer entlang und damit ich mich
nicht Schneide bewege ich am besten die
Kartoffel
[Musik]
die sind perfekt wir müssen nur bei den
Tomaten des grünen da wegmachen lecker
[Musik]
mit Milch
die Weichen auch ach so okay
aufgeweichte Kekse mit Milch
ella
du kannst dich schon aufs Abendessen
freuen
Kartoffeln Kartoffeln und Buscetta
die Tomaten die kleinen gewürfelten mit
Essig
freust Dich drauf
ja und was ihr hier auch machen könnt
wenn ihr kleine Kartoffeln habt
Drillinge zum Beispiel die könnt ihr
einfach nur halbieren die heißen so
aber so sehen sie halt aus später wieso
Brotscheiben und dann sind wir richtig
brusche
ach so jetzt versteht wir tun deshalb da
drauf ach so
was auch richtig gut schmeckt das müssen
wir auch mal wieder machen aber so ganze
Kartoffeln in den Ofen ja und dann mit
dem Käse Kumpel ja was ist dein
Lieblingsgericht Erler mit Kartoffeln
ich
[Musik]
mag anderes Gericht ohne Kartoffeln okay
wie findest du meine Spaghetti ella
Spaghetti mit Tomatensoße und Käse
die die ich mache immer aber willst Du
trotzdem gleich die Bruschetta
Kartoffeln probieren
okay
[Musik]
dann gebe ich jetzt hier Olivenöl drauf
und ich habe jetzt hier einfach unser
Rosmarin Olivenöl so habe ich direkt
Rosmarin Geschmack dabei Salz und
Pfeffer und dann einfach in den
vorgeheizten Ofen bei 200 Grad Heißluft
und dann einfach schön rösten und weil
sie ebenso dünn geschnitten sind dauert
auch nicht so lange wie eine halbierte
Kartoffel oder eine ganze Kartoffel
da hat man schnell in einer halben
Stunde ein leckeres Gericht
vielleicht mit abwaschen bisschen länger
ja
aber wir räumen ja währenddessen auf
dann geht es schnell
und es sind so Gerichte die auch eure
Kids zum Beispiel auch mal alleine
machen können weil ich muss sagen dieser
Mira kocht schon auch gerne mal alleine
für uns ja
mal natürlich die so ein bisschen darin
schwenken
dann ist überall gleichmäßig spielen
[Musik]
und dann kommen jetzt die Kartoffeln
schon direkt in den vorgeheizten Ofen
bei 200 Grad Heißluft
[Musik]
die Kartoffeln sind jetzt im Ofen dann
kannst du jetzt hier deinen Salat fertig
machen das Bruschetta soll ich kurz da
reinmachen
okay
und so ein grünes
Licht
und unsere Knoblauchzehe ist ein
bisschen riesig deswegen nehme ich mal
nur so eine halbe durch alles rein tun
ja
die Knoblauchzehe jetzt einfach so damit
wir nur den Geschmack drin haben aber
halt keine knoblauchstücke ja machen wir
mit rein dann darfst du noch Salz und
Pfeffer dazu machen wie viel
so wie die Mama
Hilfe wie viel heißt es
Zwischenzeit hier schon mal die Sour
Cream machen mit saurer Sahne
und Schmand kommt da nicht normalerweise
noch ein bisschen Zitrone und
Zwiebeln ja eigentlich man kann auch
noch Zwiebeln man kann eigentlich alles
rein machen was man will aber ich weiß
ja immer noch eine rote Zwiebel
reinmachen ja komm dann machen wir eine
rote Zwiebel rein da auch noch eine rote
Zwiebel rein und ich schmecke hier die
Sauer cream einfach mit etwas
Schnittlauch Salz und Pfeffer
was brauchen noch Salz die Tomate na ja
genau
[Musik]
regnet
die Zunge rausstreckt werden
dann hattest du sogar noch gesagt jetzt
an alle zungenleser und so echt ja
stimmt
Quatsch mache ich nicht
[Musik]
ich habe gedacht wir machen das in das
rein hatte mir das nicht vergessen
gemacht
dass meine Kinder immer Zwiebel im Salat
haben wollen ich bin immer die die
eigentlich sagt keine Zwiebel aber meine
Kinder die wollen immer
und meistens
manchmal richtig Lust auf Zwiebeln
manchmal nicht
es ist zu groß
und den Rest heben wir uns auf hier oben
drauf okay
und wenn man immer währenddessen schon
sauber macht dann hat man am Ende nicht
so viel Arbeit ja
perfekt
denn unser Essen ist gleich fertig die
Kartoffeln sind gleich da
schau mal ich habe Pizzateig Pizzateig
sieht nur noch viel aus
[Musik]
also die waren jetzt bei uns 20 Minuten
im Ofen
ihr könnt sie auch gerne ein bisschen
länger lassen falls ihr sie knusprige
haben
wenn man sie knusprige haben will
so anrichten
sollen wir wie so ein Bruschetta machen
wenn klappt nicht oder die Pommes
diese Soße machen wir aber nicht drauf
oder
die Salatsoße das trinkt ihr immer so
gerne
so dann können wir probieren ich komme
sofort
bin mal gespannt
sag ja meine Kinder sind verrückt nach
Salat Soße
[Musik]
das heißt
gerettet
es war gut
oder danke
was sagst du
mir auch
und ich finde das ist ein Rezept was man
echt gut zusammen daheim zubereiten kann
hat man innerhalb von einer halben
Stunde ein schönes Abendessen was
Leckeres auf dem Tisch und vor allem
könnt ihr jetzt noch eure Tomaten die
ihr vielleicht noch aus dem Garten habt
einfach verwenden also viel Spaß beim
Nachmachen wir stellen Euch das Rezept
in die App und wünschen euch viel Spaß
beim Nachkochen bis zum nächsten mal was
sagen
ja
ich habe mich gerade am Gaumen verbrannt
ich hasse es schnell Tomaten essen
der Käse der war schon schon abgekühlt
aber die Soße unten drunter
also aufpassen bis dann tschüss
[Musik]